i just will get a notification of a
pickup
head down to the location and there will
be a group of 20 plus
immigrants standing on the corner
waiting for ubers and they'll just hop
in and
go wherever they're going i probably
have like
four or five max trips so far it'll be
quote unquote like a family friend or
family in general
that will call and be like hey i'm
getting this uber for life for my family
it could just take them to where the
location is and then i get down and
it's legit the middle of nowhere with a
group of people and they all just get in
the car and i'm taking them to that
location the last two weeks has been
kind of hectic you see them walking
around
everywhere
well they use the uber app to uh pick up
you know request a ride
and then they would uh
they just set in the destination to the
the border patrol headquarters home
here in town and
took them down there and officially
technically it's illegal to
transport illegals
so they gave me a warning
technically they ordered from the app
although the app doesn't know that
they're legal so
i talked to
the official and they officially have to
give me a warning the officer that the
board patrol agent that i spoke to was
saying that they wanted to send out an
email to uber regarding the situation
and i called him
and i told him
it's uh
it's kind of you know
we're kind of put in between a rock and
a hard place because it's coming through
the app
and then we don't know that they're
legals until you know you start talking
to them what happened about a week ago
is border patrol was capacity was far
exceeded and they didn't have the
ability to show up in time so what
people were doing is they were waiting
at the border a couple hours and then if
it just wasn't happening they haven't
seen anybody they start moving
some of the ways was by uber
they would call an uber and then
go either some someone went to the
hospital some of them went to the border
troll station this is new this is not
something that is a normal standing
operating procedure if you would for uh
what's happened in the last nine ten
months
just last week is when
that started to change the mpp or the
remaining mexico program coming back
online
is correlated to roughly where this
happens so el paso went online first
which then shoves some of the the
traffic towards arizona so it does make
sense that that's part of what's
increasing the numbers right now
[Music]
they just seem like regular farm workers
actually
that you see walking around right now
farming season and they're cultural
but uh
a lot of them actually the both couples
both parties that i take down for venice
of minnesota
and we're here for uh the university
status and find out it's like well
too like now you know i'm not going to
just drop them off
somewhere you know say i can't do it
because you know someone would have
little kids the other was an elderly
lady that kept doing walk so
you kind of feel you feel for them
[Music]